[Música]
boa tarde tá bom e tanta boa tarde
muito obrigado aqui é o nilson amputá
ter completado a gente mais uma vez do
comida di buteco a track é a coisa mais
importante eu acho que da vida e da
minha vida eo que mais mobilizou minha
vida inteira
sua história de vida das pessoas e aqui
nós estamos vendo tantas histórias e ver
esse menino que falar sobre a a
transformação que ele vem ajudando a
comunidade é o que mais me encanta na
minha vida e é o que mais me motiva a
fazer as coisas na minha vida e quando
estou a falar dando disso e eu vim aqui
falar sobre o propósito porque eu
acredito muito nisso porque todo mundo
deveria ter um propósito na vida tanto
pessoalmente quanto profissionalmente eo
meu começou há 30 anos atrás e começou
uma empresa que era uma empresa de venda
de máquina de costura em máquina de
tricô ou provar muito dessas pessoas
falaram que não sabe o que é isso
não estou ficando muito velho mas é
verdade é talvez seja um dos mais velhos
aqui está falando esse negócio mas com
esse lugar que me transformou nós - um
brasil de extrema complexidade muito
desemprego inflação vou nem falar disso
mas é um país às vezes esperado para
muitas pessoas
e foi nesse lugar que eu aprendi a me
tornar vendedor e foi nesse lugar que me
despertou a coisa mais importante da
minha vida queria ser bom de negócio e
foi através da primeira campanha que eu
vi na minha vida que começou a mudar a
vida das pessoas no slogan desse negócio
era entre para o melhor negócio do mundo
o seu e através de máquinas de costura e
macro de tricô
a gente fazia a conta para as pessoas
mostrando que elas podiam pagar e se
sustentar até através daquele pequeno
negócio familiar que existia na casa
dela
foi ali que aquele negócio me despertou
de uma maneira e me ajudou a transformar
porque eu venho de uma família muito
simples muito pobre não tem ninguém na
minha casa que é empreendedor
o transformador de grandes coisas
simplesmente a mãe sonhava e educar
são dois filhos dela e hoje estou aqui
falando sobre isso
e foi nesse lugar que a gente
transformou a vida de tanta gente em
dois anos nos tornamos a maior loja de
venda de máquina de costura tricô do
brasil em belo horizonte no centro da
cidade
o sucesso foi tão grande que a gente se
perdeu com ele
dois anos depois três anos depois a loja
estava quase quebrada
ali eu aprendi a segunda edição na minha
vida que a gente tem que se preparar pra
gente enfrentar inclusive o sucesso que
a gente pode estar ter a gente não
estava preparado para aquele sucesso
todo que a gente teve e obviamente eu
precisava arrumar emprego
naquela época começou um programa de
trainee que todo mundo hoje acha moderno
e todas as empresas falam seu programa
de trainee com qualquer oportunidade que
eu tinha eu me candidatava e graças a
deus entrei na pepsico do brasil não é
um chip
entrei como trainee achando e me
transformar a primeira tarefa minha foi
descarregar uma carreta de 3 mil cachos
uma das coisas que a gente até r e quase
é desesperador às vezes mas é um negócio
mais importante da minha vida ali e que
o maior valor que eu tenho da minha
família é o trabalho
às vezes a gente sonha com grandes
coisas e deixe de a gente fazer o básico
levantado do dia cedo e trabalhar
arduamente
eu trabalhava 12 a 14 horas por dia
dezesseis anos depois era diretor geral
de uma operação da pepsico no brasil
o dia que eu tomei a decisão de sair da
companhia todo mundo perguntava por que
você vai sair da companhia
você vai ter uma carreira internacional
lembra da loja de costura de tricô aonde
me despertou querer ser dono
eu falei não se eu morrer amanhã e não
foi dono de um negócio vou morrer feliz
e foi nesse lugar
aquele dia que eu falei para eles que eu
ia sair da companhia
essa companhia que me ajudou
financeiramente e lapidou
para ter o conhecimento talvez que eu
enfrento hoje todos os dias nos últimos
dez anos e aparece o comida di buteco
quando eu compro comida di buteco um
sonho que a gente tinha era transformar
esse negócio a nível nacional porque eu
acredito nesse negócio compartilhar
valor porque todo mundo que tá nessa
sala
goste ou não nós vamos ter que aprender
a fazer isso tanto pessoalmente quanto
profissionalmente
a gente que é um mundo mais justo as
pessoas vão ter que aprender a fazer
isso na vida delas e todos os
empresários que passaram aqui pessoas de
sucesso
mais do que a gente fala bonito do nosso
negócio que a gente transforma o que a
gente faz a gente vai ter que aprender a
dividir isso com a sociedade
eu acredito que o comida di buteco ele
ajuda a fazer isso comigo teco é
corrente do bem porque o levante faltou
do dia desse negócio da corrente do bem
porque a nossa história começa com um
pequeno negócio familiar onde o dono ea
família está por trás deste negócio é
isso que a gente busca todos os dias
descobriu histórias de vida desses
pequenos negócios familiares
e esses casos pode ter um negócio só
participar do cometa e participar do
comida di buteco ele não paga nada
porque senão a gente jamais teria dado
oportunidade para muitas famílias como
por exemplo provavelmente muitos de
vocês devem conhecer o bairro da via
aqui dentro do chapéu mangueira que é
uma vida que estavam sendo transformada
e foi transformada pelo começo de
governo e que a gente vem ajudando não
só ele como nós temos milhões de outros
casos mais do que eu ficar falando eu
queria mostrar um vídeo pra vocês verem
a visão que um boteco tem do que a
comida
eu perguntei quem pagar alguma coisa
estivesse você vai me falar meia hora
quem pagar 10 prestação de 800 já estou
fora já tem um mundo pra pagar bem mais
um tal documento tem que falar tem que
pagar eu não quero sair não sei vou ter
que pagar nada nem agora nem depois nem
durante nem nada faltou dentro
é por isso que vocês pede que põe
avental não é mais o chefe
chique boteco é na esquina e se do
técnico ele voltar aqui é único que
resgata o sousa manuela dona joaquina
que está no botequim fazendo um pit
esquisita que é tão gostoso quanto o bar
do fulano de tal que é bacana aí onde
ele se sente importante é manter uma
mesa que um logotipo com a comida de
buteco os patos um dos principais
então a gente adquirir até minhas coisas
nossas e está mergulhando com ele até
foi nossa é a nossa vida nosso boteco
antes do começo da década um hoje é
outro
outro parte da corrente do bem é a
sociedade o que a gente acaba impactando
nela da forma que a comida a foi
concebido os botecos a espalhar pela
cidade porque estão espalhados
estrategicamente pela cidade porque ele
ajuda a integrar a cidade como um todo a
gente quer integrar a cidade
ninguém é que costuma conhecer as
cidades que vivem hoje ninguém vai a
lugares diferentes e o comida acabou
transmitindo que as pessoas voltassem a
conhecer a cidade que elas vivem
novamente mas o testemunho que a gente
tem de todo mundo que a gente abre uma
cidade foi não é absurdo alguém de forma
a mostrar a cidade que a gente vive
novamente
e esse ano tem uma coisa muito curiosa
principalmente aqui no rio de janeiro
porque o moto este muita gente ouviu em
várias cidades
o movimento que a comida vem fazendo ao
longo desses anos sabe que as pessoas
falam para nós nós vai começar o comida
di buteco vai começar um mês da
felicidade
isso não tem preço gente esse talvez
seja o maior valor agregado que não
estamos deixando na sociedade
impactantes as cidades e atualmente
comida vem
a impacta mais de 6 milhões de pessoas
a gente tem um alcance de mais três
milhões na rede social
e a gente tem mais de 650 mil votos
porque as pessoas precisam os botecos
pra votar isso um negócio de alto
engajamento
mas tem que ter pessoas que acreditam na
nossa causa
tem que ter pessoas que acreditam no
nosso sonhos há 12 anos atrás eu cheguei
nesse lugar aqui e foi o arapuan que
acreditou no nosso sonho quando comida
de buteco ninguém nem sabe o que quer
aqui no rio de janeiro e as pessoas vão
perguntar o que esse negócio que vocês
fazem e foi a primeira pessoa que
acreditou que talvez o público de boteco
poderia agregar na cidade e impactar a
cidade de forma positivo lá atrás ou as
doze anos depois eu estar aqui talvez
nem ele nem ninguém só acreditaria que a
gente estaria aqui no palco hoje falando
sobre comida de boteco e falando dos
impactos do comida di buteco proporciona
impacto na sociedade e hoje eu vou
confessar uma coisa vocês que eu nunca
compartilhei com ninguém eu quase
desisti desse sonho nosso e por quê
porque em 2008 e 2009
nós perdemos mais de um milhão e meio de
reais eu falar assim comigo nó será que
eu vou perder minha vida inteira aqui em
[Música]
25 anos de trabalho e só foi fundamental
naquele momento vamos falando disso
[Música]
eu acordava e pensava comigo amanhã vou
trabalhar mais que deus fecha uma porta
ela é doce 2010 a gente reverteu o
prejuízo que a gente vê e começamos a
gerar lucro e é isso que falta de pé
aqui falar desse negócio e muitas
pessoas têm que acreditar no nosso sonho
e eles acreditaram na gente
ninguém sabia se esse negócio dar certo
é que nem eu
o que a gente aprendeu ao longo dos anos
é o comida di buteco demora oito dez
anos para dar certo uma cidade
sabe por quê porque ajudar as pessoas e
transformar a vida das pessoas e não vai
transformar em um dia em dois anos e 1
12 anos se leva anos para ajudar a
integrar essas pessoas dentro da
sociedade
eu queria passar o vídeo pra gente a
falar desse negócio de opinião deles
como eles enxergam esse negócio hoje
[Música]
motivar os donos de bares empreendedores
é nesse ramo tão tão necessário para o
aumento do nosso estado do nosso país é
vocês fazem com brilhantismo e nós aqui
da amisom acreditamos muito nisso então
nossa parceria é campeã e acredito que
estaremos juntos é muito mais tempo e eu
quero que isso continue cada vez mais
forte e produtivo para todos nós muito
obrigado valeu comida de boteco temos
muito prazer em estar junto deles vendo
a evolução desses empreendedores
brasileiros com raj coragem com garra é
um público que funciona ou mais
empregados sendo contratados e mais
pessoas que com conseguem gerar uma
renda para a família delas então para a
chandon esse projeto e segundo foi
fundamental
tem um lado social muito forte e tem
também uma democratização do consumo do
espumante no país que é um país é no
brasil que é um país altamente promissor
eu queria agradecer o cabo cabo frio que
representou a plano
muito obrigado por isso por isso que as
pessoas quando faz as coisas com uma
naturalidade tem que receber em dobro e
espero que deus ilumine muito por causa
dano e ter contribuído muito pouco mesmo
tempo também lá atrás e os parceiros nós
porque eles são tão importantes e
relevantes porque em 2014 o comida di
buteco foi premiado foi homenageado
tentar globo há como os projetos de
grande inclusão socioeconômica e foi
apresentado à família marinho por isso
que esses caras estão com a gente até
hoje ocorrida hoje era mais de 140
milhões nós já saímos da cnn já são três
vezes o new york times já saímos
principais veículos do mundo inteiro e
hoje talvez tx os em transformar numa
das maiores plataformas do brasil e isso
faz a gente levar o nome do país pra
fora é isso que vai valorizar a questão
do brasil fora dessa questão da
sociabilização da forma da gente
consumir as coisas você pode eu queria
mostrar um testemunho só da pessoa da da
globo como eles enxergam comida de
boteco
[Música]
o de buteco ele é um desbravador
é quase um bandeirante né porque ele vem
abrindo caminhos no brasil para pequenos
varejos para pequenos negócios pequenos
bairros
[Música]
e o outro elo opa e outro elo da
corrente do bem
é o poder público porque o poder público
porque um barulho da via que era um bar
ilegal dentro da comunidade
a gente conseguiu alvará de
funcionamento para ele e foi através dos
indivíduos poder público da prefeitura
que ajudou esse trabalho a gente faz em
várias cidades porque muitos vários que
começam com comida às vezes não têm nem
alvará de funcionamento são várias as
vezes que começa com 10 mil reais
faturamento mas eu tenho história a
gente tem muitas histórias de sucesso
bares que chega a faturar já tem um
queixo sucesso que passou de 1 milhão de
reais faturamento mesmo com o mesmo
técnico
então se é isso que é transformador e
quando a gente fala de reconhecimento
aqui a gente vencendo a embaixada
estados unidos há dois anos fez um
intercâmbio cultural de gastronomia do
brasil estados unidos eles escolheram
comida de buteco volta eu voltei ele ou
não só pra mim acabado de falar e só do
negócio ea gente vai fazer um trabalho
com criança esperança que é uma coisa
junto com o globo pra gente levar a
história de empreendedorismo levar
pessoas que têm obtido sucesso na vida
delas e uma fonte de geração do primeiro
emprego pode passar
[Música]
a homenagem marca o início da edição do
comida de buteco 2018 que está na sétima
edição em são paulo
então esse convívio essa disputa
saudável ela tem que ser valorizada
do ponto de vista econômico e social do
ponto de vista cultural
[Aplausos]
a gastronomia de minas nacional e
internacionalmente
[Música]
e pra finalizar o último elo da corrente
do bem que a gente fala ela gira a
partir do momento que havia desses caras
são todos formados e devolve tudo pra
sociedade que ele recebeu de graça
na verdade é de volta através da geração
de emprego através da geração de
impostos e eu vou terminar e queria
terminar com uma coisa mais importante
que as pessoas me pergunto todos os dias
o que eu faço eu levanto todos os dias
para contar histórias de vidas que
comida ajuda a transformar e eu queria
terminar com esse vídeo aqui de uma
história transformada pelo comigo tempo
olá pessoal do comida di buteco é estou
aqui pra falar da shell um recado pra
vocês
falar que o dia aqui vieram aqui e me
escolheram para participar do comida di
buteco foi um sonho que pra mim é se
tornou realidade porque eu trabalhei um
ano atrás acontecer isso a minha mãe
veio falecer um câncer
e eu falava para ela que eu queria
participar desse concurso me dá
credibilidade para mudar que tinha
certeza que a gente podia se dar bem
nesse concurso
e vocês conseguiram encaixar no concurso
me fazer participar desse concurso então
ganhar o concurso mudou minha vida tanto
que vocês não têm idéia
é eu era uma pessoa que estava triste
estava entrando em depressão vocês
conseguiram fazer a mudança minha bebida
totalmente me dá ânimo vontade de
trabalhar
o trabalho de vocês foi importante da
credibilidade que me deu e um sonho que
se realizou para mim eu acho que vocês
têm que continuar esse trabalho é
incessantemente por que vocês podem
mudar a vida de pessoas anônimas vocês
fizeram eu eu ganhar aquele dia na
reunião é na reunião na festa de entrega
dos prêmios quando eu estava lá é que
vocês mandaram todos os barcos a pista
hora que você se reunir as pessoas
começaram a soltar e chegou ao primeiro
lugar vocês falam vamos gritar junto a
vocês militar o campeão é o bardo xandão
vocês transformar a minha vida porque eu
não era tão conhecido e vocês me deram
uma credibilidade que você amou a emoção
da minha vida eu poderia morrer hoje que
eu estou satisfeito com o que eu fiz foi
a maior emoção que eu tive na minha vida
mas o chandon hoje é uma pessoa muito
mais feliz
uma pessoa realizada fez um trabalho eu
acho excelente porque senão não tinha
ganho e agradeço muito a todos todos
eles foram anjos que vieram na minha
vida pra me ajudar porque é uma
credibilidade grande as pessoas me
enxergam vinha gente de longe de bater
foto é comigo com o filho no meu colo
sabe para que serve um artista
participar do concurso comida di buteco
eu fui considerado aqui na vila matilde
como ayrton senna da vila matilde
então estou muito feliz por isso e muito
obrigado muito obrigado que deus abençoe
vocês obrigado por tudo
[Aplausos]